here's one corporate media outlet that
is willing to acknowledge some of the
struggles men face but the prescription
they offer is downright terrible it
would be hilarious if the issue wasn't
so dire
this article that was just published
comes from the Washington Post and it's
written by a woman of course and it's
it's impressive in one sense which is
that it manages to reach exactly the
wrong diagnosis on every single aspect
of the problem
the article is called men's groups are
embracing an alternative conception of
American masculinity
now the whole thing reads like a parody
so if you're able to check it out
immediately I can't recommend it highly
enough The Washington Post wants to give
us the real story about why men are long
lonely and how best to combat that
epidemic and and what's their suggestion
well
just to summarize basically they say
that dudes should lie around doing
breathing exercises and smelling incense
while some guy named arua gropes them
and Whispers stuff like this quote I
invite you to maybe bring up an
intention how you want to live in this
world
how you want to love in this world how
you want to be in this world
that's not an exaggeration that's a
direct quote from the article the men's
groups that are the article profiles are
not these aren't Bible studies or flag
football leagues you know the kinds of
men's groups that men would actually
want to join now these are new age
touchy-feely group hugs where men learn
how to get in touch with their feminine
side
later in the session that is uh being
documented there by the article The Men
start screaming and sobbing and crying
and letting their emotions quote flow
freely as they are quote released into
the darkness
now the article goes on to quote a bunch
of experts Who quote unquote experts who
all say The Familiar things about how
men are lonely and lost because of toxic
masculinity that encourages us to be too
stoic and too reserved and so forth it
laments the quote Cowboy mentality that
has allegedly contributed to the problem
now the masculinity expert who coined
that phrase about the cowboy mentality
is a woman named naobi way and she of
course quickly identifies the real
victims in the story of male loneliness
can you guess who the real victims are
who's most put upon by male loneliness
well naobi says it's women
think of the women men are lonely women
most impacted
she says quote women end up being the
therapist for their husbands and more
are getting sick of it
yes God forbid wives have to listen to
their husbands and offer them Solace and
comfort they're sick of it says
masculinity expert niobe
that's not a conflicting message at all
is it on one hand men need to open up
more but on the other hand if they do
open up then they're putting an unfair
burden on their wives who are being
asked to do too much emotional labor
okay then
by the way women uh just a quick note if
you feel like you're sick of hearing
about your husband's troubles just keep
in mind that he hears about yours about
a thousand times more often you know a
company is looking out for you and they
actually upgrade your service and don't
charge you for it this is uh great news
for new and current Pure Talk customers
pure talk just added data to every plan
and includes a mobile hotspot with no
price increase whatsoever if you've
considered pure talk before but haven't
made the switch take a look again for
just twenty dollars a month you'll get
unlimited talk text and now 50 more 5G
data plus their new mobile hotspot this
is why I love Pure Talk they're veteran
owned and only hire the best customer
service team located right here in the
great USA most families are saving
almost a thousand dollars a year while
enjoying the most Dependable 5G Network
in America remember you vote with how
you spend your money so stop supporting
woke wireless companies that don't
support you when you go to puretalk.com
Walsh you'll save an additional 50 off
your first month because they actually
value you that's puretalk.com Welsh
puretalk Wireless for Americans buy
Americans most people only think about
poor air quality when we have fires like
the ones that just happen in Canada
causing New York to be a strange orange
color that made the air quality
absolutely terrible but if you stop to
think about the polluted air in your
day-to-day life you and your family's
health may be affected by the air
quality in your home allergens and germs
floating in the air you breathe can make
you sick but the good news is that
there's technology out there that helps
you purify your living space easily and
affordably within viral cleanse you'll
never have to worry again Enviro cleanse
is an in-home air purifying unit
designed to destroy cold and flu viruses
allergy inflaming toxin molds and even
more Enviro cleanse promises far fewer
cold allergies and better sleep their
air purifiers come in all sizes colors
and prices to fit every budget and they
offer additional products like a Surface
Cleaner and laundry detergent and viral
cleanse is the air purifier we use in
our home and I love it to give me the
peace of mind that I need than to know
that my family is breathing healthy air
the last thing I need with how often I'm
traveling is to get sick and for anyone
in the family to get sick and viral
cleanse offers a simple solution for
keeping me healthy and are family
healthy and tip top shape breathe in
pure air and live a healthier life visit
ekpure.com and use code Walsh for 10 off
your Enviro cleanse home air
purification unit right now you also get
their free air quality monitor Test Plus
fast free shipping that's 150 in savings
ekpure.com code Walsh that's ekpure.com
promo code Welsh now meanwhile a
consultant named Mark green says this
quote
if a boy expresses too much emotion or
too much need for connection is too
giddy is too joyful what we say to that
boy is what are you a what are you
a girl what are you gay it's your job to
dominate those around you or you'll lose
status and that will increase the number
of individuals above you who can dish
out dominance to you and what we find is
that in that system in that structure
men are constantly in competition with
each other and constantly driven by this
sense of anxiety
so that's the real problem too much
competition too much stoicism too much
uh men are too combative and aggressive
and we gotta calm all that down
well the problem with this theory is
obvious
or it should be
okay if a cowboy mentality and too much
Macho stoicism is what is driving the
epidemic of lost and lonely men
then why is the problem getting worse
over time
everyone agrees it's worse now than ever
before I just went through some of the
many statistics that prove that is a
major problem yes men are in bad shape
but if that's all getting worse then how
can we blame traditional Notions of
masculinity there's no doubt that it's
far less common for boys to be called
sissies these days or labeled gay as a
pejorative
I can't remember the last time I saw a
boy being uh lambasted as a
because he's being emotional that almost
never happens anymore used to be very
common
and again it certainly was more common
um
you know back in the day 50 years ago or
any other time in human history
indeed historically the push for a man
to be strong and dominant and
unemotional was much more pronounced
than it is today in fact historically if
a man didn't exhibit those traits
then he would die and his whole family
would die it's only in recent times that
it's even been a feasible option for men
to be feminine and soft and in touch
with their feelings
and it's also in recent times that men
have lost all sense of themselves and
their purpose and place in the world
speaking of the cowboy mentality why
didn't actual Cowboys have these
problems if a cowboy mentality leads to
Despair and suicide then we should fight
a whole hell of a lot of it when we look
back at the latter half of the 19th
century which was the era of the cowboy
but that's not what we find
you know the post overall thesis can
probably be best summarized in this
sentence from the article quote American
men's isolation stems in large part from
a pervasive cultural belief experts say
that men should be self-reliant and hide
their emotions especially from other men
the absurdity of the premise could not
be any more clear
would anyone argue that the cultural
belief that men should be self-reliant
and hide their emotions is more
pervasive today than it was half a
century ago
of course not so again if that's the
cause of the problem
why is the problem worse today
the trends are clearly going the other
way the correlation Works entirely in
the other direction as Society loses
traditional Notions of masculinity
suicides increase this is undeniable
it's not debatable
you could try to explain that
correlation away all you want but if you
deny it or pretend it doesn't exist
you lose all credibility in this
discussion
now these experts are correct that men
need fellowship and men are missing it
these days and that is part of the
problem definitely
but they even missed the point on that
end too even when they're right they end
up being wrong because they encourage
men to Fellowship in the way that women
fellowship
you know they tell men to sit around and
talk about their feelings do some yoga
listen to soft music hold each other and
cry that's not the kind of Fellowship
men need or want
okay we can't expect corporate media's
masculinity experts to understand this
because their masculinity experts are
all effeminate but any normal man can
attest that men tend to bond
while engaging in a shared activity and
I don't mean yoga okay I mean like one
that doesn't require a lot of talking
like sitting and watching the game or
fishing or golfing playing pick up
basketball and so on
I went out fishing with my
brother-in-law a few weeks ago and um
when we came back my wife asked me what
we talked about
and I said I don't know nothing really
you didn't talk about anything
you didn't talk about it well we talked
about fishing
you went fishing you just talked about
fishing what's going on in his life
what's going on what did you talk about
we didn't talk about much
she she was shocked and confused because
women don't operate that way but men and
women are not the same
and you cannot hope to help men or offer
them any road map out of Despair if you
don't start by acknowledging that basic
fact
now when it comes to True male
Fellowship the problem is that Society
has closed off many of the opportunities
for that kind of Fellowship there are no
men's lodges anymore there are very few
bowling leagues and that sort of thing
most men's spaces have either been shut
down or feminized it's been decided that
men should socialize like women and with
women or not at all
yeah women barge into every male space
and say I want to be a part of this too
include me
and then the men just end up walking
away from it they say it's not so
pointless now now that you're here
frankly
it's like the men's Lodge exists because
to be a place where you aren't so that
so that we don't have that we don't want
that here
well that hurts my feelings I want to be
included in everything
and then those same women turn around
and say well why are men fellowshipping
at all
well maybe because you won't butt out
maybe because you won't allow it
maybe because you want to make
everything about you
this is the message across the board
Society beckons to men and tells them
that their salvation is to be women and
then we wonder why so many men are
killing themselves
we live ultimately ultimately for all
the talk of patriarchy we do not live in
a patriarchy ultimately we live in a
matriarchal society with institutions
either run by women or by effeminate men
who in their arrogance simply cannot
accept the fact that men are different
from women and have different needs and
desires
so this is the real problem
it's not that men are too focused on
masculinity it's that masculinity has
been neutered castrated driven out of
society leaving men feeling lost and
without purpose
our Notions of masculinity aren't too
traditional on the contrary they aren't
nearly traditional enough
the solution isn't that we sit around
and talk about our feelings
it's that we do a whole lot less of that
sort of thing and get back to being men
again
and if we can be men in a society that
Embraces and values our masculinity
suddenly this tide of male loneliness
and despair will start to ebb
that is the solution
there is no other hey YouTube thanks for
listening to the show if you'd like
access to my full show with no ads you
should go to dailywire.com and use promo
code Walsh to get two months free on all
annual plans see you there